10 different filmmakers from different
corners of the world joining together to
make one project
hello this is masood and i'm from iran
my name is kedar sonigrah i am in bombay
my name is anita isen i'm from
yokiakarta indonesia hey my name is
mayar and i am in damascus syria i'm
diedam tali and right now i'm in
istanbul turkey my name is miri shuffman
i'm from davis california in the central
valley my name is sophia kosairu and i
live in london my name is mohan
and i am in tunis i love being a
storyteller for so many different
reasons from other people's stories we
can see life with a wider perspective
being a storyteller and a journalist
helps you also to expand your
perspective empathize with people
understand people
just dipping into the life of someone
who you've never met and getting a
chance to get to know somebody
because everybody has a story everybody
has something to say
as humans no matter what our background
is we always have many more things in
common than our differences